dans le port de bayonne était amarré
jusqu'à ce matin un paquebot grecque
auparavant il battait pavillon français
c'est un paquebot de croisière le world
de renaissance
il est arrivé hier soir avec à son bord
cinq cents passagers qui effectue une
croisière pélérinage rome fatima est
lourd deux dernières étapes
mais ce que l'on retiendra de cette
halte dans ce port aux bayonnais bien si
tout d'abord c'est une première et
deuxièmement cette escale pourrait être
le point de départ d'une nouvelle
activité la croisière voici le reportage
de nathalie pinard et denise des us à
bayonne la nuit ce que le world
renaissance est entré dans le port de
bayonne terme d'une croisière de douze
jours au départ de toulon fin d'un
voyage et début d'un autre ce matin le
paquebot a largué les amarres pour
londres sur les traces de victor hugo à
bord de 120 passagers principalement de
la région
embarquez pour quatre jours sur
l'atlantique disposant des activités les
plus variés de la piscine à la
discothèque
une première qui est lourde d'enjeux
économiques pour le port qui se lance
dans une nouvelle activité mais aussi
pour l'ensemble du pays basque saute pas
double intérêt un d'intérêt d'abord de
faire connaître d'autres régions aux
croisiéristes qui font escale ou qui
viennent terminer leur croisière ici et
c'est une promotion donc de notre région
et ensuite cela permet aussi d'avoir un
impact sur l'économie locale dans la
mesure où l'on sait que tous les
passagers de croisières viennent
toujours malgré tout dépenser un petit
peu d'argent à terre et que ce soit le
commerce que ce soit certains services
qui existent ici dans notre
circonscription profitent de passage
donc de ses croisières oublier la
nostalgie remettant au goût du jour les
grands périples d'autrefois by homme
s'ouvre ainsi de nouveaux horizons avec
le world renaissance la ville prouvent
ses capacités de port de croisière
disposant d'un potentiel de clients
suffisant pour les cette croisière
prévue dans l'année les passagers
attendus ne seront pas forcément
aquitain une activité aéroportuaire avec
la mise en place d'un système de
charters pourrait être envisagée par les
agences une véritable invitation au
voyage